una nueva ola de kobe 19 golpea con
fuerza a europa las autoridades
sanitarias recomendaron a los estados
considerar una dosis de refuerzo de la
vacuna contra el coi 19 como mínimo seis
meses después de completar un primer
programa
estamos muy alarmados acabamos de pasar
tristemente la marca de 15 millones de
muertes la semana pasada si continuamos
en el curso actual estamos proyectando
más de medio millón 500 mil muertes para
la primavera del próximo año eso es
realmente preocupante
webber son aptos esta semana francia
registró más de 30.000 casos positivos
las autoridades aumentaron los controles
en los lugares públicos donde es
obligatorio portar el pase sanitario en
la quinta ola de la pandemia acaba de
empezar las personas que no tienen el
pase sanitario no pueden estar en
lugares públicos si queremos controlar
la epidemia hay que hacerlo con el pase
de salud
en alemania entró en vigor la regla de
las tres g es decir hay que estar
vacunado o curado y testeado por sus
siglas en alemán la normativa que se
implementará en el transporte público y
en el lugar de trabajo ha incrementado
la vacunación y las dosis de refuerzo y
en suecia el gobierno comenzará a
implementar gradualmente la dosis extra
de la vacuna
en hanford todas las personas de 18 a 65
años recibirán una tercera dosis de la
vacuna la recomendación es que la dosis
se administre seis meses después de la
segunda dosis
menos del 70% de la población general de
la unión europea ha recibido la pauta
completa lo que deja un gran espacio
para que el virus se expanda